c'est le visage de la catastrophe celui
d'omar hassan chef 13 ans coincée sous
l'eau au milieu des débris de sa maison
trois jours d'agonie filmé par les
caméras colombienne le 13 novembre 1985
le volcan nevado del ruiz entre en
éruption en pleine nuit
plus de vingt mille personnes sont
surprises par un mélange d'eau et de
cendres ils sont des centaines de
réfugiés à dormir comme cela dans les
rues en attendant un abri ou des
nouvelles des proches qui sont restés là
bas la catastrophe aurait-elle pu être
évitée
dès septembre des géologues ont tenté
d'avertir le gouvernement local
sans succès autre alerte la présence de
fumerolles ces émanations de gaz
volcaniques sont les prémices d'une
éruption et en octobre
le volcan se réveille un peu plus au
mois d'octobre l'eau du lac se
volatilise des panaches de vapeur que
les habitants d'armero pouvait voir de
chez eux
c'était le second signal d alarme qui
s'accompagnait de secousses de plus en
plus fortes de plus en plus fréquentes
malgré ces alertes la région autour
d'armero n'est pas évacué les
conséquences sont dramatiques
armero et rayé de la carte en quelques
heures
des épidémies se déclarent une église
fait office de dortoir pour les réfugiés
et les secours tentent de s'organiser
dans les villages les plus proches les
hôpitaux ont été improvisés les blessés
y arrivent sans discontinuer au rythme
des rotations d'hélicoptère on soigne
avec les moyens du bord du carton en
guise d'attelle et on soigne et c'est
cela le plus important
au milieu des rescapés cette femme qui a
perdu presque tous les membres de sa
famille selon elle le gouvernement
colombien est le principal responsable
de la tragédie les autorités même dans
les tous derniers moments disait ton
gens que rien n'avait se passer leur
demandait de rester chez elle tout
simplement de fermer les portes et puis
et puis c'est tout vingt-trois mille
personnes sont mortes dans la
catastrophe
aujourd'hui armero n'est plus qu'une
ville fantôme ces habitations sont en
ruine et la nature a repris ses droits à
l'abandon également les tombes des
victimes du nevado del ruiz
[Musique]